[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
we're back
walter yes we're back
and we're gonna discuss again like
always important
discussion
well we did say at one stage
that we will have to address spiritual
issues
as well we cannot only stay with
news items and where we are but how does
it affect us and what kind of decisions
must we personally make yes because
the reason why we use the news articles
and in every episode we show about that
we try
to get it back to the spiritual in any
case always because that's where it ends
it has to be linked to
a spiritual situation and a spiritual
conflict
it's called the great controversy it's a
battle for the mind correct so let's
open the word of prayer
our heavenly father
we know that this battle for our minds
are raging that's why we need the holy
spirit to help us to guide our minds and
we ask that now in jesus name amen amen
now
i know that this topic causes much
consternation
at many levels
and we've titled that righteousness by
faith and corporate repentance
and
it's a very very touchy issue
and it deals with the church as a whole
so shall we put a disclaimer in from the
very beginning
how do we understand the church
i can only understand the church
in harmony with what scripture says
about the attributes of the church
so if you read there in revelation
well let me take the good book and read
it
if we go to
revelation chapter 12.
in chapter 12 of the book of revelation
it talks about the woman which is the
church
and how
the lord took care of her for 1260
days or years
during the period of papal suppression
and then
there was
a
situation where the earth helped the
woman and she became prosperous
she became prosperous in those areas
where the nations did not have the power
to oppress her as it was when she was
amongst the nations of europe
but with peace comes complacency and
that is always a problem right
and so eventually
there was
a remnant that remained
and the dragon was roth with that
remnant so that's after the 1260
days so sometime after 1798
there must have been an awakening
as to
the real biblical values
and the dragon is wrath with that woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed so there will be a remnant that
arises here
in the last days and
they are very well defined they keep the
commandments of god and have the
testimony of jesus
so this remnant
is a church
because it is a woman
that keeps the commandments of god
now the bible is quite clear that if you
say that you keep the commandments and
you break one you break them all right
correct and there are ten commandments
not nine commandments
and they are
what god says they are and not what the
usurper changes them
to be according to his whims
all right so we have those criteria we
know when she arises
we know what she does
and we know that she has the testimony
of jesus now if you go to revelation
chapter 19
then we understand
from what the angel
describes there in verse 10
where john falls at the feet of the
angel to worship him and he said unto me
see that thou do it not i am thy fellow
servant and of thy brethren that have
the testimony of jesus
worship god
for the testimony of jesus is the spirit
of prophecy
so this remnant
has
the spirit of prophecy in other words
the prophetic gift to guide them through
the quagmire of this world correct they
don't the the verses don't say they just
believe in the spirit of prophecy that's
in the bible correct the spirit of
prophecy refers to the prophetic
pronunciations throughout time but this
remnant specifically has the spirit of
prophecy
and they have a very special message
and you find it in revelation chapter 14
and
we are told in revelation chapter 10
that there must be
a prophesying again
and then it tells us quite plainly
what it is that must be prophesied again
and i saw another angel flying in the
midst of heaven having the everlasting
in other words the unchanging gospel
that hasn't been altered and manipulated
and wrenched out of its position
to preach unto them that dwell on the
earth and it has to be a universal
message because it goes to every nation
kindred and tongue and people
so we need to find the church that keeps
the commandment that has the the
testimony or the spirit of prophecy that
is a universal church and that preaches
the three angels messages and you can
search high and low
there's only one there's only one
there's only one
and that is why
i am a seventh-day adventist
and i assume that is why you are one
right yes
not because we were so attracted
by the beauty of it
but because we were compelled by the
biblical
assertions that this is so
so the lord has a
church he has a universal church
he has a church that is represented
internationally
that keeps the commandments of god
and
that holds to the testimony
which is the spirit of prophecy which
they have
now
does that mean everybody in the church
is on the same wavelength
no
no because we also read in the same
bible that the wheat and the tares grow
together until the harvest
now who sowed the tares satan satan
sowed the tears and the donal
looks exactly like the real thing
until the fruit develops
then you can distinguish between them so
by their fruits you will know they know
them
so unfortunately we sit with a situation
where we cannot run
because this is the remnant
and its condition
is also described in the book of
revelation namely it's a loudesty and
condition
which means that they think they are
rich because they have so much knowledge
about scripture god has blessed them
beyond measure
but in actual fact spiritually they are
blind
naked
and rigid and wretched and they need
isolf so that they can see
and they're counseled to buy
gold refined in the fire in other words
they must develop a character
which is in harmony with the word of god
and
the only way to develop such a character
is to appropriate the righteousness of
christ
so the righteousness is of christ is
absolutely important and you can only
appropriate it by faith
exactly now what is the righteousness by
faith because you get justification by
faith
but righteousness by faith is more than
just justification by faith
justification is a judicial
decree
that you have
been clothed with the robe of
righteousness
that is imputed to you although you are
undeserving
but imparted righteousness
must also be appropriated by
faith
that is you must open the door
you must give permission
for christ to come into your heart and
remove the dross through the refining
fire
and change the heart of stone into heart
of flesh so righteousness by faith
incorporates justification as well as
sanctification
but you have to appropriate it by faith
now how do we know when we see someone
that he has been clothed with the
righteousness of christ
his fruits will tell you
by the fruits
that's the only way that you can do this
so with that as a background let us say
god has a people
god has a people that keeps the
commandments of god
god has a people that hold to the
testimony
right yes
and god has a people that is willing to
stick their neck out to preach the three
angels messages contrary to popular
opinion yes that's it
now within that same church there are
many
that would rather put the brakes on
and say no let's not do that it's been
like that throughout the ages
and the history of israel tells us
what we should beware of
there will be ahabs
there will be jezebels very active
within the church leading people to sun
worship yes and wherever there's a
product
unfortunately there's also a buyer
yeah
[Laughter]
so there are buyers for
babylonian doctrines within our church
and if you have faithful witnesses who
stand against it
there will be clashes
clashes of the mind and these can become
quite vociferous
and
they can
they can even turn quite nasty yes
and then you will have ostracizing and
marginalizing and
name calling one of the favorites is
conspiracy theorist
whatever yeah
so name calling is one of the weapons
yeah that's satan it's one of the fruits
yes it's one of the fruits so we have to
be
very careful
but
the church is the apple of the lord's
eye
and within this this body you will have
this variety of fish
and when those fish are sorted one day
some will
be retained and some will be discarded
so the issue of corporate repentance
will there ever be a time when the whole
church
will come into harmony
that will have to study right
okay so with that as a disclaimer from
the beginning
i belong to this church because i
believe it is biblical
i believe it has the right message
and i believe it is the crucible
in which the refining takes place
that's where
the stones and all the
scruffy stuff gets
chipped off okay we get rid of the rough
edges right
yes sometimes
it gets quite painful and you think you
know should i run
but
you know the disciples were also
confronted with that at one stage when
so many turned their back upon jesus
and jesus went and looked at them and
said do you also want to go
yeah
and peter answered where shall we go
lord you have the words of eternal life
there's nowhere else to go
okay so let's dive right into it
there was a time in the history of this
church
when it had
grown to the point where it was becoming
more prosperous
and the message that was going out
particularly the health message and all
of these was you know receiving favor
even from prominent people in the world
and this church has been blessed with a
with a health message
and hospitals were built in sanitariums
and even the great leaders of the world
would turn
to these institutions to find relief
from their maladies
and then of course with prosperity
there is always the great danger that
the adversary will get his
knife in there right
and this happened with kellogg
one of the most brilliant physicians
that
was ever part of this church
and
the impact that he had was enormous
but then he wrote a book called the
living temple
in which he started
basically elevating
their stature
[Music]
and pantheistic ideas started creeping
in
so we read in letters and manuscripts
the following
i did not read living temple though i
had it in my library at last my son said
to me mother
you're to read at least some parts of
the book that you may see whether they
are in harmony with the light that god
has given you he sat down beside me and
we read the paragraphs to which he
referred
when we had finished
i turned to him and said these are the
very sentiments against which i was
bidden to speak in warning at the very
beginning of my public work
when i first left the state of maine it
was to go through vermont and
massachusetts to bear a testimony
against these sentiments
living temple contains the alpha of
these theories the omega would follow in
a little while
i trembled for our people
these beautiful representations are
similar to the temptations that the
enemy brought to adam and eve in eden
now
this word i tremble
tells you that this is a very serious
issue
and that many will be deceived by some
of these sentiments
and they are serpentine yeah and they
seem beautiful yes they seem beautiful
because
they
uh
lift the ego
we know that the world by its own wisdom
cannot acquire a correct knowledge of
the true and living god when christ came
to this world clothing his divinity with
humanity
the treatment he received from the
highest authorities of a nation who
professed to know god
made fully manifest the strength of
human reason and wisdom
so martin what we are reading here is
that human wisdom and human reason is
going to be placed above thus says the
lord that's it
we've had many many programs
where we discuss
jesuit thinking and reason informed by
faith
and what the jesuits say about human
reason how it supersedes the word of god
in fact they totally negate the word of
god by their reason
so the heart could not form correct
views of god through his way and his
works
a new revelation came by jesus christ
who represented the father he declared
him to the world in living his law in
humanity
every specification of it that's very
important
he didn't break any precepts
neither by the letter
nor by the spirit correct he didn't make
any mistakes on that issue no
and through faith in jesus christ he
makes it possible for man to live that
law
as man accepts the righteousness of
christ
he is a partaker of the divine nature
he may keep the commandments and live
the law of god as the apple of his eye
so martin who within the church
represent the apple of the lord's eye
all the individuals that keep the
commandments and live
to according to the law
okay now
can you do this in your own strength no
no you have to appropriate the
righteousness of christ right the only
way nothing you can do can do it so this
is a divine intervention
in humanity
and only through that divine
intervention
are you enabled
to perform this right
so let's read it again as man accepts
the righteousness of christ
he is a partaker of the divine nature he
may keep the commandments and live the
law of god
as the apple of his eye
that's the bottom line
if in the book of evangelism here we
read a very important statement how do i
know martin
that someone has appropriated the
righteousness of christ again it will be
shown by his fruits
all right so let's read it
several have written to me inquiring if
the message of justification by faith
is the third angel's message and i have
answered it is the third angel's message
in verite
now the third angel
wands against accepting the mark of the
beast
which is the mark of authority of an
antichrist system
in other words how do you prove that you
have the right
to
command above what scripture says
and the roman catholic church says the
proof lies in the fact that we change
the sabbath to the sunday which gives us
that authority and proves that we have
the authority because we did it and the
entire civilized world follows what we
are saying that's arrogance of the
highest order but nevertheless that's
what they're saying yeah
okay and it's actually easy if you put
it into logic
if you come to somebody and he says to
you do this because i say so and you do
it you acknowledge that he's got the
authority to tell you to do it correct
now the other point is of course
that
why you are doing it is because of this
power's coercion
but that's not what god wants
he wants you to give him permission to
work within you the righteousness of
christ
right yep so there's a difference
definitely the one is a form of
submission and the other one is a form
of arrogance and elevation yes the one
is obedience and the other one is just
going with it with the flow
so it is righteousness by faith that is
at the heart of the issue
why am i keeping the commandments
because i have faith that jesus can
transform that which was lust into that
which can be eternally in the presence
of god yeah
okay that's beautifully put
so what does righteousness by faith do
it presents an uplifted savior
this message was to bring more
prominently before the world the
uplifted savior the sacrifice for the
sins of the whole world
it presented justification through faith
in the surety
there's no doubt about this
it invites the people to receive the
righteousness of christ
which is made manifest in obedience to
all the commandments of god
that's
beautiful
so how do i know that someone has really
appropriated the righteousness of christ
he keeps the commandments of god yes
it's made manifest by that obedience
because who is working that obedience in
that individual christ christ that means
you have submitted to him and have
chosen to follow his way rather than the
world's way
so it proves that you
have
appropriated that righteousness we must
not forget this statement because this
is becoming a very important statement
in this discussion
how do i know that someone or an
organization if you want has
appropriated the righteousness of christ
it will be made manifest by obedience to
the commandments of god
now martin that does that just
apply to ten little commandments or are
the commandments so broad that they
incorporate the whole moral issue of
humanity has it has to com incorporate
all
it is complete because he added nothing
more yeah and nothing can be taken away
many had lost sight of jesus they needed
to have their eyes directed to his
divine person his merits and his
changeless love for the human family
all power is given into his hands that
he may dispense rich gifts unto men
imparting the priceless gift of his own
righteousness to the helpless human
agent
this is the message that god commanded
to be given to the world it is the third
angel's message which is to be
proclaimed with a loud voice and
attended with the outpouring of his
spirit in a large measure
so the outpouring of the holy spirit
the latter reign that we are waiting for
has to do with the righteousness of
christ
correct yes now who will give that
message
the people that's keeping the
commandments those that have
appropriated the righteousness are the
only ones that can preach that
righteousness exactly
how do you know that they've
appropriated it by keeping their
commandments correct so again
you know
it's a it's an argument that cannot be
refuted
this is the way it is
so if you want to know whether
we are in harmony with god or not
then we have to look at this issue and
the fruits will tell us
here's another statement from faith and
works
by living faith by earnest prayer to god
and depending upon jesus merit
we are clothed with his righteousness
and we are saved
again
it is a dependence
so in other words the human instrument
has to
place itself in a subservient position
acknowledge
that we in our own strength are
incapable and appropriating the strength
of christ and he will work the works in
you
so our job is to die
yes daily daily okay
oh yes some say we are saved in doing
nothing
in fact i am saved
i need not keep the law of god i am
saved by the righteousness of jesus
christ well christ came to our world to
bring all men back to allegiance to god
to take the position that you can break
god's law
for christ has done it all is a position
of death
for you are as verily a transgressor as
anyone
then what is it
it is to hear and to see that with the
righteousness of christ which you hold
by faith
righteousness supplied by his efforts
his divine power
you can keep the commandments of god
just in case we think that we are the
bee's knees
so in other words
it is an issue
where
you have to appropriate that
righteousness because you are not
capable
and then by the fruit you will see
whether you've actually appropriated it
or not yeah
does that make sense yeah definitely
it's a logical conclusion
it has to be like it has to be like that
right
okay
let's continue on this
road
god's remnant church page
paragraph three
we are to stand firm as a rock to the
principle of the word of god remembering
that god is with us
to give us strength to meet each new
experience
let us ever maintain in our lives the
principles of righteousness that we may
go forward from strength to strength in
the name of the lord
we are to hold as very sacred the faith
that has been
substantiated by the instruction and
approval of the spirit of god
from our earliest experience until the
present time
martin
this has to do with spirit of prophecy
yes it's not only written for the 1800s
correct
we are to cherish as very precious the
work that the lord has been carrying
forward through his commandment-keeping
people
and which through the power of his grace
will grow stronger and more efficient as
time advances
the enemy is seeking to becloud the
discernment of god's people
and to weaken their efficiency
but if they will labor as the spirit of
god shall direct he will open doors of
opportunity before them for the work of
building up the old waste places
their experience will be one of constant
growth until the lord shall descend from
heaven with power and great glory
to set his seal of final triumph upon
his faithful ones
so this is going to be a battle and a
march
until the very last days and satan will
try to close doors
and god will open doors
if we are faithful
second selected messages
the least transgression of god's law
brings guilt upon the transgressor
and without earnest repentance and
forsaking of sin he'll surely become an
apostate that's a warning that's a
warning and that just brings the thought
that sometimes if you not don't want to
walk that
path that we've just read in the
previous one you'll start thinking up
excuses from some of these things if you
cannot overcome these things correct but
we have to also balance it with other
statements
there's a beautiful statement which says
it's not the occasional
good deed
or the occasional
misdeed that determines our standing
with god
it is the trend
of your life
so yes there will come times when we
will stumble and we will often have to
come to the feet of jesus to confess our
faults and our shortcomings
but our trend should be in a particular
direction striving towards that goal
let us as a people as far as possible
cleanse the camp of model defilement
and aggravating sins when sin is making
its march upon the people who claim to
be elevating the moral standard of
righteousness
how can we expect god to turn his power
in our behalf and save us as a people
that did righteousness if as a people
we do not keep ourselves in the faith
and not only advocate with pen and voice
the commandments of god but keep them
everyone not violating a single precept
knowingly then weakness and ruin will
come upon us it is a work that we must
attend to in every one of our churches
each man must be a christian
so this seems to be an individual
war
and whether we'll ever get the whole
corporate body to move in this direction
is probably
not something that we can expect soon
truths more sacred than any ever
imparted to mortals upon earth have been
committed to our trust yet
we as a people have not been faithful to
our trust
our fruits have borne witness that our
faith is weak and inefficient unable to
accomplish god's design
our unfaithful sabbath keepers are the
worst enemies the truth can have
that's a tremendous statement
there's power in the truth and it will
work a thorough reformation in the life
when it takes hold of the heart many
have taken hold of the truth but the
truth has not taken hold of them
so do we have a situation in the church
where
we will sit with this conflict
until the close of time yes and i think
it will also escalate and get a little
bit heated more heated so
what's the biggest problem the biggest
problem is unfaithful sabbath keepers
because they become the worst enemies of
the people of god yes they proclaim with
their mouth but the fruits indeed speak
contrary yes they will take the
scriptures
and they will say this is inspired and
this is not inspired they'll take the
testimonies and say oh this is only a
letter and this is that whereas she
plainly states that even if it is a
letter
then she wrote it under that inspiration
could we do the same with the bible
could we say well you know what about
the letters of john that he wrote to
individuals should they be in the bible
that is what higher critic bible
scholars are doing all the time all the
time now do we have higher
critic bible scholars in our ranks yes
some of them have studied at
prominent institutions yale for example
or other institutions and they become so
wise that they know more than the
scriptures they know which portions are
inspired and which were written by
ignoramuses
but the bible says all scripture is
god-breathed
and useful for that's it all scripture
all scripture but again if you have
these individuals or you look at these
people
then the statements that we've just read
and if you compare it to the bible
they're fruits
they will tell you i'll tell you
all right so we're going to have
conflict we're going to have conflict in
the church and we're never going to get
to a point
where all the tears turn into wheat
right because that's not scriptural no
right so let's carry on with our letters
and manuscripts seventh-day adventists
are handling momentous truths
more than 40 years ago the lord gave us
special light on health reform
but how are we walking in that light
how many have refused to live in harmony
with the councils of god
we as a people have not made spiritual
advancement proportionate to the light
received
it is our duty to understand and respect
the principles of health reform
it's today just as important
maybe even more important than it was in
that time yes and particularly in the
time that we are now living in is very
important that
we make decisions that are in harmony
with the righteousness of christ
that means christ working in you the
hope of glory that's it not you
determining for yourself what is right
and what is wrong
or determining for someone else what is
right and what is wrong and coercing him
in into doing whatever your whim is yeah
or even if you do get confirmation from
god in your conscience going contrary to
it that would be a dangerous thing
so on the subject of temperance we
should be in advance of all other people
and yet they are among us well
instructed members of the church and
even ministers of the gospel
who have little respect for the light
that god has given up on this subject
they eat as they please they work as
they please and the result will surely
follow in a cheap experience in
spiritual life
so we can expect that as well martin
should that dishearten us no it's
easy to get disheartened
but we cannot afford the luxury
of being disheartened
now when we go back to the experience
of
where the latter rain was to be poured
out upon god's people
and unbelief
created a situation where the spirit of
god was eventually withdrawn
and we went back into the wilderness and
we've been there a very very long time
and i believe
that the events in history which cannot
be held
are bringing us to the point where the
outpouring of the latter rain
will again
be
prominent
who will receive the latter rain some
people are waiting for the corporate
church
to be ready to receive the latter rain
i have a horrible feeling in my stomach
that we are waiting in vain for that to
happen
but there are people within the church
on every level from the highest level
to the lowest level
that will receive the latter reign
so let's have a look at
what happened in 1901
at the general conference session
i feel a special interest in the
movements and decisions that shall be
made at this conference
because in 1888
they actually started off with
appropriating the message of
righteousness by faith but then it faded
right yeah
so here was an opportunity at this
session
regarding these things that should have
been done years ago and especially ten
years ago
when we had assembled in conference and
the spirit and power of god came up into
our meeting testifying that god was
ready
to work for his people if they would
come into working order
the brethren ascended to the light god
had given
but there were those connected with our
institutions especially with the review
and herald office and the conference
who brought in elements of unbelief
so that the light that was given
was not acted upon
it was ascended to
but not no special change was made to
bring about such a condition of things
that the power of god could be revealed
amongst the people you know modern if
you are sent to something
you admit that that is the right thing
but you don't do it yeah
then there's no fruit
it's like people who say i know health
reform is right but i need time to eat
what i drink what i want to until
sometime that i am convinced yes well if
you know what is right then you should
be convinced already that's it that's
right it comes back to don't think of
excuses
rather work on your situation
so they're ascended to the yes it's
right but i mean the bible has an
example of that of the child that say
that
it's better for somebody to say no i
will not do it and do it than somebody
to say yes and not do it correct
although even the one who said i won't
do it not that he you know should
receive accolades but the fact that he
did it
in the end is at least gratifying
so the light then given me was that this
people should stand higher than any
other people in the face of the whole
earth that they should be a loyal people
a people who would rightly represent
truth the sanctifying power of the truth
revealed in their lives was to
distinguish them from the world
they were to stand in moral dignity
having such a close connection with
heaven
that the lord god of israel
could give them a place in the earth
year after year the same acknowledgement
was made but the principles which
exalted people were not woven into the
work
god gave them clear light as to what
they should do and what they should not
do but they departed from that light
and it is a marvel to me that we stand
in so much prosperity as we do today
it is because of the great mercy of our
god not because of our righteousness
that his name should not be dishonored
in the world
this has been a pattern
lip service
but no
real
embracing
and
you know
subsequent to this
people say but the church did
appropriate the righteousness and they
are preaching righteousness by faith
but is it a question of assenting and
not really doing
so why did the shower cease after the
revivals of 1888 and 1901 and
1903. god was very patient with this
church
well the book of jeremiah provides
an answer
let's just
look at it
jeremiah chapter 3
they say if a man put away his wife
and she go from him and become another
man's
shall he return unto her again
shall not that land be greatly polluted
but thou has played the harlot with many
lovers yet return again to me says the
lord
it's a
it's quite a
striking analogy right
because we are the bride of christ
lift up thine eyes unto the high places
and see where those not been lean with
in the ways has thou set for them as the
arabian in the wilderness and thus
polluted the land with thy whoredoms and
with thy wickedness therefore the
showers have been withholden
that's the reason
why
because they interacted with the heathen
nations
and they weren't faithful to god that's
it they broke the marriage vow as it
were
and there has not been the latter reign
thou had a forehead
and thou refuses to be ashamed
that's
very straightforward language
will thou not from this time cry unto me
my father thou art the guide of my youth
will he reserve his anger forever
will he keep it to the end behold thou
spoken and done evil things as the
cutest
so that was the situation
in the type yeah
and we are told over and over again that
we are improving on the type that's it
and also another important thing here is
will he reserve his anger forever
the god that we serve is very merciful
jeremiah 3 verse 12 go and proclaim
these words towards the north
babylon yeah
and say return thou backsliding israel
says the lord and i will not cause mine
anger to fall upon you for i am merciful
says the lord and i will not keep anger
forever
only acknowledge thine iniquity
that there has transgressed against the
lord thy god and has scattered thy ways
to the strangers under every green tree
and you have not obeyed my voice says
the lord turn o backsliding children
says the lord for i am married unto you
and i will take you one of a city and to
our family and i will bring it to zion
it's actually a very sad verse
so
it seems as if a remnant of a remnant
will actually listen
yeah the rest are stuck in babylon one
of a city two of a family i will bring
it to zion
so many will not heed this warning
and they will continue
as he says
prostituting themselves to the nations
around
and preferring their company
to their marriage vow
so the north
to assyria and media that lay northward
from judea whether the ten tribes were
carried by
tiklat pileza and salmoneza
so they had scattered those northern
tribes and judah still remained
so the north was also babylon the
northern tribes had been scattered by
the assyrians and judah was about to be
taken captive by babylon
they were to become exiles in babylon
they were given an opportunity to return
or to remain there if they so wished
luther spoke of the babylonian captivity
of the church
so
there was a literal application and a
spiritual application
now we have a remnant
i wonder whether some of the the remnant
is in babylonian captivity spiritually
definitely do you think so
so what was the main issue of the
reformation
to bring them out of that babylonian
captivity and are we going to repeat
history again
the issue was righteousness by faith
that's it righteousness by faith
is what brought about the reformation
the just shall live
by faith that started the reformation
now if that could start a reformation
and release a people
from babylonian captivity couldn't it
happen to us
it has to so must we rediscover
righteousness by faith yes
where does the power lie
in
in god in jesus in jesus how's it made
manifest by keeping the commandments
okay
so we always come back to this point the
fruit is obedience
so did the reformers stick to their guns
in other words they said righteousness
by faith is the issue and they separated
from rome
no they failed miserably at the council
of trent and then embraced babylon in
the joint declaration on justification
once you make a compromise
you are on a very slippery slope
then recently
at that same church in trent
there was again a signing of a document
of all these
protestant
denominations with the papacy
correct so it just is something
that tells us that history repeats
itself over and over again
the solution is appropriating the
righteousness by faith which will be
made manifest by keeping the
commandments so there at the first
council of trent when that archbishop of
reggio walked into the council and said
you are not a church you are a bunch of
rebels because you say that you believe
the bible
but you keep sunday
which is against your
moral standard your bible you keeping
sunday which is the command of the
catholic church therefore you are only
rebels
what did they do
no they kept to that they they kept to
the sunday in other words did they have
the righteousness of christ no no
because it's made manifest in keeping
the commandments how many of them all
all of them
so they gave it up what's the result
eventually it took 500 years
but the result is that they signed the
joint declaration and went back to rome
that's it and negated the blood of the
lamb
is it possible that that can happen in
the remnant as well
well it can certainly happen in a
portion of the remnant because wheat and
tears grow together right
and that the babylonian principles
become more acceptable
than thus says the lord i'm sure it
could happen
so let's go to the remnant
what was the issue of 1888
the same
is god bringing us
back to the same point
over and over and over again he has to
because that's the only way eventually
that you can be saved what was the issue
in the fledgling church that christ
created
righteousness works all righteousness by
faith it was righteousness by faith then
we went back to works
then the reformation came what was the
issue
righteousness by faith then there came a
remnant yeah that keep the commandments
and hold to the testimony
and then the issue of righteousness by
faith came up what is more important
your works in keeping the commandments
or christ working in you enabling you to
keep the commandments and they said no
no
no we don't want to go along with this
and so
the showers were withdrawn and they
ceased
so the issue was righteousness by faith
well in 1888 did the leaders accept it
no no they attributed the revival that
took place to fanaticism
that's what they labeled it
fanaticism
and could it happen again
today they call it legalism
well let's read and say first selected
messages
there have been things written to me in
regard to the moving of the spirit of
god at the last conference that was in
and at the college which clearly
indicate that because these blessings
were not lived up to
minds have been confused and that which
was light from heaven has been called
excitement
fanaticism
i've been made sad to have this matter
viewed in this light we must be very
careful not to grieve the holy spirit of
god in pronouncing the ministration of
the holy spirit as a species of
fanaticism how shall we understand the
workings of the spirit of god
if it was not revealed in clear and
unmistakable lines not only in battle
creek but in many places
so the church then
some of them acted upon it
and others rejected it
now it's interesting that the leaders
that were in harmony with outpouring
later in their experience became
apostate yeah
is that a reason to deny the veracity of
the movement no no many a bright light
will go out right exactly
so
we cannot base our conclusions on what
the future decisions of someone will be
it is dangerous thing to doubt the
manifestations of the holy spirit for if
this agency is doubted
there's no reserved power left by which
to operate on the human heart
those who attribute the work of the holy
spirit to human agencies saying that an
undue influence was brought to bear upon
them are cutting their souls off from
the fountain of blessing
whatever may be the sin if the soul
repents and believes guilt may be washed
away by the atoning blood of christ
but he who rejects the revealings of the
spirit of god and charges the work of
god to human instrumentalities
is in danger of placing himself where
repentance and faith will not come to
him
so it's very dangerous to say
that what some people are saying and
doing
because it doesn't harmonize with their
opinions is not from god right
and it's also dangerous when you tell
somebody tells some a person
you should
act according to his conscience by the
help of the holy spirit
but as long as that is in harmony with a
common narrative
that's a very dangerous thing yes
let's read this last sentence here the
evil one casts his hellish shadow
between the soul and god
and the work of god is looked upon as
excitement and delusion
very dangerous thing
the spirit strives in vain
for all the sufficiency of the gospel is
inefficient to subdue the soul and
correct the error
the habit of resistance is so fixed
he has so long interpreted light to be
darkness and fanaticism that the most
manifest working of god's holy spirit
becomes to him not a savior of life unto
life
but through his unbelief a savour of
death unto death
that's basically what you said
if the spirit of god is working contrary
to someone else's narrative
it's very easy for that individual or
that organization to say
but these people are preaching
fanaticism that's it
we should not be drawn into that kind of
thinking what if god is trying to make
something prominent exactly and they're
throwing cold water onto that every time
and you see that's what's scary because
like the statement says the habit of
resistance is so fixed yes they've
become so accustomed to have this and
i've heard
this also before
be very careful when you have resistance
immediately
because then you will have to defend
that resistance for a while
in once you've said it so say for
instance i say no
i don't believe this
you've created that resistance and
you're going to defend it and it's going
to be hard to acknowledge if you're not
if you're wrong yes well some people
will by circumstances
eventually have to acknowledge that they
might have been on the wrong side right
exactly can still happen
so here is a statement in first selected
messages when the students at the school
went into their match games and football
playing
when they became absorbed in the
amusement question satan saw it as a
good time to step in and make of none
effect the holy spirit of god in molding
and using the human subject
so one of his tactics
when the spirit of god is being made
manifest is to divert the attention to
some worldly activity
and in those days it was spot that
suddenly came into our institutions and
competitive sports
and it's amazing
how that diverted the mind from what the
holy spirit was doing
to
these activities
so satan has many activities that he can
place in the place of
the real thing it is and he always uses
it
something that's very popular at that
stage in the world yes it is an easy
matter to idle away talk and play away
the holy spirit's influence
if his love of amusement and striving
for the mastery absorb his power or
ability then god is not made the first
and best and last in everything so satan
will have many many
distractions to keep us busy
a revival of true godliness amongst us
is the greatest and most urgent of all
our needs
to seek this should be our first work
there must be earnest effort to obtain
the blessing of the lord
not because god is not willing to bestow
his blessing upon us but because we are
unprepared to receive it
martin
this is the most important thing that we
as a people should be working
towards are we
ready to receive the latter right
do you believe
as we've discussed in our previous ones
that what has been happening now in our
history and this whole world on a
universal scale
was just a stepping stone to the final
event yes
do you believe that the final events are
upon us yes
if you believe that
mustn't you also believe that the time
for the outpouring of the latter reign
has come then definitely
so if that time has come what must
people beware of
all these deceptions and distractions
and a revival of true godliness is the
most urgent of all our needs
so how do we attain that
we have to appropriate the righteousness
of christ through faith because in our
own strength
we won't achieve it
i cannot like
martin luther did before he
accepted this great light take a whip
and whip myself into obedience
or into repentance i have to appropriate
the righteousness of christ
so when the spirit's power touches their
hearts then the discourses given will
not be without effect
guided by the teachings of god's word
with the manifestation
of his spirit in the exercise of sound
discretion those who attend our meetings
will gain a precious experience
and returning home will be prepared to
exert a healthful influence
our messages
must be geared to the times that we are
living in that's it
now martin
are there efforts
even within our own ranks well let's be
specific particularly
in our own ranks
to negate the message as just a glitch
on the horizon yes to put off the coming
of christ saying this is not it this is
not a spiritual issue this is just a
momentary
health issue and labeling the people
that do say it as fanatics the same that
happened with the people in those days
so if we continue with one selected
messages the old standard bearers knew
what it was to wrestle with god in
prayer and to enjoy the outpouring of
his spirit but these are passing off
from the stage of action and who are
coming up to fill their places how is it
with the rising generation
are they converted to god are we awake
to the work that is going on in the
heavenly sanctuary
or are we waiting for some compelling
power to come upon the church before we
shall arouse
are we hoping to see the whole church
revived
that time
will never come
this is probably our most important
statement
in this entire presentation
can we expect a corporate revival within
the church
no
are we hoping to see the whole church
revived
that time will never come
now modern there are those that preach
that the church must conform otherwise
christ can't come well then he will
never come
so in other words those that are
willing
to appropriate the righteousness of
christ
and
who bear the fruits
which is they will receive the latter
reign
and the others will call it fanaticism
that is where we're heading
yes that's where we're heading
so what will be our situation
under those circumstances
we have far more to fear from within
than from without
the hindrances to strength and success
are far greater from the church itself
than from the world
that's a very sad statement
but if we do not read these things
we're not reading this to be judgmental
no let me put it straight we're not
reading this to be judgmental but if we
do not read them
we will become disheartened
and confused
and we will say
well
what must we do now
it seems to me that this body is doing
this and
we feel that our conscience is driving
us in this direction and the two are at
loggerheads with each other who do you
obey
god you have to obey god
you have to appropriate the
righteousness of christ which is made
manifest by keeping the commandments of
god okay
so unbelievers have a right to expect
that those who profess to be keeping the
commandments of god in the faith of
jesus will do more than any other class
to promote and honor by their consistent
lives
by their godly example and their active
influence the cause which they represent
but how often have the professed
advocates of the truth proved the
greatest obstacle to this advancement
the unbelief indulge the doubts
expressed the darkness cherished
encouraged the presence of evil angels
and opened the way for the
accomplishment of satan's devices
so we have far more to fear from within
than from without
and again
we will have to have a sharp
discernment to determine
is that from god or is that not from god
it is so important that you say that
because
unfortunately most of these things will
be happening at a higher level in the
church
so then you will have to have that sharp
discernment
and not put your faith in man you have
to put your faith in god
now let me reiterate again
we are not talking about levels of
obedience within the church
it is an individual choice through every
echelon from the leadership to the
layman
i don't believe there is a lament in the
church yeah we're all children of god
we're all children of god
so we cannot prepare the way by gaining
the friendship of the world
that's a very important point we cannot
prepare the way for the outpouring of
the latter reign by
gaining the friendship of the world
why because that's enmity with god
but by his help we can break its
seductive influence upon ourselves and
upon others we cannot individually or as
a body
secure ourselves from the constant
temptations and relentless and
determined foe but in the strength of
jesus we can resist them
so in other words friendship with the
world is enmity with god
and aligning yourself with anybody that
is contrary to the will of god is a very
dangerous thing
in the times of of ahab and jezebel i
think it was a badaya
that hid
the prophets of god and the priests of
god
in caves by the 50s two caves 100 people
whereas the rest of them were preaching
the doctrines of jezebel and ahab
and
that which was pleasing to the ear
now
i'm afraid many of god's people are
actually hidden in caves
today yep
and i wish they would come out of the
cave
and confront the issues
i know that jezebel is furious and wants
to remove them from the face of the
earth
and ahab is just too willing to do her
bedding
but nevertheless it takes courage to pop
your head out of the cave and say
excuse me there's a right way and
there's a wrong way
what are god's commandments
they are the wall which is built around
his people there is to be no departure
from his principles no bringing in of
worldly policy principles
no worldly customs or practices are to
be brought in for this people who are to
be representatives of christ to follow
when we keep the commandments of god we
are in touch with god and he is
connected with us that's the bottom line
that's it then we've got righteousness
by faith then you have righteousness
by faith so let's ask a few questions
these are not comfortable questions and
they're not designed again
to attack
they are designed to alert
and to
tear us out of this complacency
and out of this reliance
on someone else's opinion
because we have to form our own opinion
with the help of the holy spirit correct
if it has doesn't have the holy spirit
in it
then it'll have the other spirit in it
yes simple as that so again the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
has to be the basis upon which those
decisions are made right
so we ask ourselves a question since
1888 and 1901 and 1903 when that spirit
was just so desirous of being poured out
when it was eventually withdrawn has the
church turned round
well have we as a people done any of the
above
have we done what we've spoken about
have we as a people therefore embrace
the message of righteousness by faith
we claim we have
yes we've painted lip service
but how is it made manifest
we have to see the fruits we have to see
the obedience right
so the claim we have but whether it is
so is to be made manifest by obedience
to all the commandments
no more than this all the commandments
of christ
had they accepted it they would not have
the following
they would not be involved in economical
movements which are strictly forbidden
by god isn't that a plain statement
claim
all right let's be fair is the whole
church involved in echemianism no are
all the leaders involved in ecommerce no
no are many of the leaders involved in
ecommerce yes
yes are many of those trained in
institutions where they have drunken
from the wells of babylon yes
okay
and are they influential in terms of the
voice
unfortunately very influential yes
but they're not bearing a fruit of
righteousness by faith because god has
forbidden what they are involved in
so then you have to take that into
account
now martin recently they had a meeting
at the church in trent
and the catholic priests cristiano
battega were welcomed to participate
pence with the following words
our churches have been carrying out a
path of encounter a path of mutual
recognition
a path also of healing of wounds
those wounds that history has produced
and the consequences of which we still
see today through many divisions
a journey in which the beauty of being
brothers and sisters is continually
rediscovered even beyond the
distinctions between the churches of the
orthodox tradition
either of the protestantism tradition or
the catholic tradition
and there's no doubt
that representatives have been
associated with this economical movement
and some of our
people are actually
in
positions of authority within this
ecommerce movement even vice chairs
of some of these
movements and this is highly problematic
because we have two different ideologies
that are clashing
one which is called a beast with a mark
and you're not supposed to be associated
with him or you will receive of his
plagues come out of her
and here is another movement which tries
to integrate us
it is not a fruit
according to righteousness no
because we are clearly told in letters
and manuscripts that the world is not to
be our criterion we are not to associate
with the ungodly and partake of their
spirit for they will lead the heart away
from god to the worship of false gods
the steadfast soul firm in faith can do
much good
he can impart blessings of the highest
order to those with whom he associates
for the law of the lord is in his heart
but we cannot willingly associate with
those who are trampling
upon the law of god and preserve our
faith pure and untarnished martin are
they trampling on the law of god yes and
it spills over into other things exactly
like the state i say it's only the
fourth commandment that's the law
if you break one you break them all
we shall catch the spirit
and unless we separate from them we
shall be bound up with them
at last to share their doom that's
exactly what revelation chapter 18 says
and warns against
so
it is a very sad state of affairs but
there are certain mindsets within our
ranks that are not in harmony
with this principle and therefore it is
causing division within the church
now you can actively war against it
or you can decide to ignore it
and then my question is what authority
can an institution exert
when they are not in harmony with the
principles of
righteousness dare you appropriate their
recommendations without investigating
them for yourself
no that's very dangerous
and that will
inflict on your conscience
yes
now we must also remember that many of
the so-called christian leaders in the
world are also members of secret
societies and particularly of the
freemasons
and god has warned that we should not
associate ourselves
with these people who call it the
confederacy
quoting isaiah
and then we read in the book evangelism
there are those who question whether it
is right for christians to belong to
freemasons and other secret societies
let us all consider the scriptures
just quoted
if we are christians at all we must be
christians everywhere we must consider
and heed the council given to make us
christians according to the standard of
god's work i cannot sit around the table
in an economical council knowing full
well that many of those represented
there are also members of freak of
secret societies
satan will use his agencies to carry out
diabolical devices to overpower the
saints of god
as in times past he used the roman power
to stay the course of protestantism
let's just read the highlighted portion
the evil confederacy can advance only
in the course which jesus has marked out
before them
every step of their advance brings the
saints of god nearer the great white
throne
nearer the successful termination of
their warfare
the confederacy of evil will finally be
destroyed for the prophet says behold
the day cometh that shall burn as an
oven and all the proud yea and all that
do wickedly shall be stubble
in the day that cometh shall burn them
up says the lord of hosts that it shall
leave them neither root nor branch
martin
we have such clear
directives
that also brings to mind to me now that
you've stu
in the disclaimer
the wheat and the tears
who bundles the tears eventually to be
burnt
it's it's the angels and god will burn
it correct we're not supposed to do
anything no we this is not our job but
we have to look at the fruit
so the second point
to determine whether we've appropriated
the righteousness by faith
is
they were not embracing nazi and
spirituality by introducing spiritual
formation emerging church theology
willow creek theology and new theology
do we find it in our ranks oh yes it's
prevalent so corporately
there is evidence that the righteousness
of christ has not been appropriated
because why would we drink at the wells
and at the systems which do not hold
water
right now we don't have to go into the
details as to
how the church has introduced in many
many places ignazio and spirituality
especially in our colleges
or emerging church theology or willow
creek theology which is actually
a course in some of our institutions
or the new theology
those who connect with the office of
publication should be men of sterling
principle
many will look to god daily men who have
learned thoroughly the fact that eternal
vigilance is their only means of safety
in fact the only safe course for any to
pursue is to work in accordance with
gospel principles and to allow nothing
to swerve him from them
we cannot preach worldly techniques
when we have to have personal
relationships with jesus christ
taking his righteousness into our soul
would the body as a whole or portions of
it sanction abortion
it cannot because then it can't qualify
to be the remnant it's contrary to the
commandments it's made manifest by
keeping
all the commandments
zion said the lord has forsaken me and
my lord has forgotten me can a woman
forget her sucking child
that she should not have compassion on
the son of a womb yea they may forget
yet will i not forget thee behold i have
graven thee upon the palms of my hands
the lord of hosts said
he that touches you touches the apple of
his eye
he's talking to the church
but just as there were ahabs and
jezebel adherents in the church
in the time of israel
so we have similar situations today
and it's also important to remember
ahab and jezebel where did they sit in
the hierarchy of israel yes they were at
the top
the fourth point they would not make of
none effect the spirit of prophecy nor
would they contradict it in their
articles and books nor would they be
ashamed of it or ashamed to distribute
it nor would they
mutilate it by reducing it making it
gender neutral changing the bible
quotations to those from moment roman
manuscripts
it would just not happen no
this is the result of higher criticism
and there are people that constantly
raise their voice
against people that preach a straight
testimony and say how can you take
a letter from the spirit of prophecy and
even call it spirit of prophecy that's
cultish
that's cultish and how can you believe
every word in the word of god you have
to filter it through your modern
knowledge yeah they say that if you say
the bible is inerrant
then you cannot be a bible scholar no
you have to be a scholar from one of our
great institutions in the world
in order to understand that the bible
cannot be fully trusted
so martin have there been attempts to
make the spirit of prophecy of
non-effect yes many right
or to distort it yeah
or to make it want to read what you
wanted to read when it doesn't read what
you want them to
water it down to that not be as harsh
or fifth they would not endorse the
union of church and state to enforce
decrees contrary to conscience
they cannot say in one sentence
that they honor freedom of choice
and in the next sentence say that you
have to do
what the state demands that is contrary
to your conscience
correct
no they would you would stay strictly
neutral on this point
and by taking a position
of aligning church and state
in whatever capacity
and when it comes to the mark of the
beast this will become very prominent
because the state will say this is for
the common good that we are doing this
and for climate change and we have to
obey the dictates of the state because
that is the right thing to do you can't
do it you can't do that and you cannot
bring nds but this is international law
so we'll rather
even though it's not national law it's
international law
then you're going to bring state and
church together correct and if you once
you start bringing church and state
together
you are aligning yourself with the image
of the beast
the church's duty is to warn a people to
come out of that situation not to align
yourself with those
philosophies let me just reiterate this
is not an attack upon the church it's an
observation
there are elements within our church
that as point six says over here that
would wish to coerce or dictate
conscience
under the
umbrella of accepting your freedom of
choice nevertheless telling you and even
using and applying force
in order to make you see it in their
particular light
that's a very dangerous thing
when to ask christ shall we liken the
kingdom of god or what comparison shall
we compare it with
he could not employ the kingdoms of the
world as a semitude in society he found
nothing with which to compare it
earthly kingdoms rule by ascendancy and
physical power
but from christ's kingdom every carnal
weapon every instrument of coercion is
banished
if that fruit is not there
then it is evidence that the
righteousness of christ has been
rejected
and they become drunk on power
that's a very dangerous thing once you
think that you can lord it over someone
else and dictate their conscience for
them even if you think you're doing it
for god
it's not supposed to be like that yes
they think they are doing god's service
i mean you can take nebuchadnezzar as an
example when he made a law that no that
the god of daniel is the only god and he
must be obeyed that's also wrong that's
also wrong
people have a freedom of choice you
can't swing the pendulum from one
extreme to the other extreme
it's interesting that when jones
defended
the cause of the adventists in 1888 when
the blair bill was coming in senator
blair
said to him
aha but if the shoe was on the other
foot and we were making a sabbath law
then you would defend it right you would
say that was a wonderful idea and jones
said absolutely not we would be just as
vehemently opposed to that as we would
be against your supposed sunday law
that's it and that's how it should be
and that's how it should be they should
be
neutral when it comes to decisions of
conscience there is no reason or
justification for coercion
the seventh point is would the church
embrace pharmaceut of the world and the
medical councils of the world over the
councils of god
no you cannot it's not a fruit that is
in accordance with the righteousness of
christ
and we have very clear directives on
this issue
here is an open letter
that was written by raymond obamzuwan to
the leaders of the church in 2021 in
june 2021.
now we spoke in our last
talk about what happened to ramon de
bamsuwen dr bomzerman
died suddenly
and his symptoms were very very severe
and
there are those that believe that all is
not fair as to what transpired there
and as we said there was no autopsy
and even the blood samples were
destroyed so that something couldn't be
done about it
but this is a very wise letter that he
wrote
and
the man has done a great work
in the vineyard of god
so let's read what he wrote letters of
counsel to all elected leaders and all
departmental heads of the seventh-day
adventist church gc
and of the
north american division
i am writing with respect to a most
serious crisis that the seventh-day
adventist church organizational
leadership and laity worldwide
have unsuspectedly entered into
although we face great peril
we also face great opportunity
it is all a matter of choice
to get our proper bearings let us first
consider carefully some deeply
instructive church history
circa 1912 a small delegation of sda
conference leaders from southern
california traveled north by train to
saint helena the mission
to explain to the lord's messenger at
almshaven why it is now deemed essential
that the newly established college of
medical evangelists cme
should become formally associated with
the american medical association the ama
in response to their careful put
proposal alan white did not in the least
equivocate in advocating for
and defending god's clear and repeated
counsel that we as god's church are not
to be tied by so much as a thread with
the institutions and organizations of
this fallen world
whose leaders neither know god nor honor
his law
she went on to enumerate the many
unwanted dangers and pitfalls that
compromise on this vital issue would
bring upon us as god's people
it was god's purpose that cme
should invent the most advanced healing
system in the world
and by example transformed the medical
practices of the world
with no small degree of disappointment
the brethren left and headed back south
after some months the same leaders made
a second journey to elm's haven their
mission unchanged
god's messenger reaffirmed their
position even more emphatically finally
however this time after much
longer period of waiting the same
leaders had the audacity to make a third
journey north to almshaven for the
self-same undertaking
when ellen white's assistant informed
her of their arrival and its purpose she
refused to meet or speak with them
on their journey home with some degree
of relief they took her silence as
license
for example at least she didn't say no
this time
so it was that cme shortly thereafter
came under the auspices of the ama
council on medical education
i won't go into the negative
implications of this tragic step
except to make a few points
and then he makes a few points
we were not to have any worldly
association in the meantime we are
associated and that's why we are under
pressure to
conform to worldly opinions and medical
opinions
we should never have been in that
position it is contrary to the will of
god and contrary to righteousness by
faith yes
it's scary
how it started
just by twisting words to satisfy what
you want to defend
point number eight they would not
indulge higher criticism and manuscript
criticism to the point where the word of
god contradicts itself and negates the
spirit of prophecy
i don't think we have to say too much
about that about questioning the
testimonies
when you find men questioning the
testimonies finding fault with them
and seeking to draw away the people from
their influence be assured that god is
not at work through them it is another
spirit
doubt and unbelief are cherished by
those who do not walk circumspectly they
have a painful consciousness that their
life will not abide the test of the
spirit of god whether speaking through
his word or through the testimonies of
his spirit that would bring them to his
word
instead of beginning with their own
heart and coming into harmony with the
pure principles of the gospel they find
fault
and condemn the very means that god has
chosen to fit
up a people to stand in the day of the
lord
we cannot expect a corporate
acceptance of righteousness by faith
but
throughout all the echelons
there will be individuals
that accept it abundant light has been
given to our people in these last days
whether or not
my life is spared my writings will
constantly speak and their work will go
forward as long as times are lost
my writings are kept on file in the
office and even though i should not live
these words that have been given to me
by the lord will still have life and
will speak to the
people so martin
if we decide to follow the dictates of
the spirit of god
and stick to the law and to the
testimony
then
we will be able
to stand with those
that
receive the latter reign that is what we
have to do as a people
i thank god for the assurance of his
love and that i have dailies leading and
guidance i'm very busy with my writings
early and late
i'm writing out the matters that the
lord opens before me the burden of my
work is to prepare a people to stand in
the day of the lord
that's what it's about
are our people reviewing the past and
the present and the future
as it is unfolding before the world are
they heeding the messages of warning
given them
is our greatest concern today that our
lives shall be refined and purified and
that we shall reflect the simultute of
the divine
this must be the experience of all who
join that company who are washed and
made white in the blood of the lamb
they must be arrayed in the
righteousness of christ
his name must be written in their
foreheads they must rejoice in the hope
of the glory of god
christ has engraved the names of his
people in the palms of his hands he will
never lose his interest
in any dependent soul
all right so let's start wrapping this
up martin
we'll just read the highlighted portion
happiness is to be achieved by the right
action of the soul towards god
we have such wonderful counsel
if we heed it
and say to god lord i'm not capable in
my own strength
but work within me
the hope of glory and come inside and
clean the soul temple and bring me into
harmony with your will your attitude
towards
how you
want to get rid of things in your life
determines how god can help you
yes it must be a attitude of submission
to his will if i want to defend what i
have you're not going to let god work
yes and then she says never have
testimonies been more clearly brought
before the people than those that have
recently been traced by my pen god bids
me urge upon the attention of our people
the importance of their study
let this work begin now
then whether i am permitted to labor or
i am laid away to rest until jesus come
these messages are immortalized they're
given for a purpose not to be ignored
regarding the testimonies nothing is
ignored
nothing is cast aside but time and place
must be considered
nothing must be done untimely some
matters must be withheld because some
persons would make an improper use of
the light given every jot and tittle
is essential and must appear at an
opportune time
every jot and tittle isn't that the same
that the bible says about the law it's
the same
situation not one jot or turtle will be
taken away from the law
you cannot take one jot or turtle away
from the spirit of prophecy so
these gentlemen and these people
that array themselves
against what is written in the spirit of
prophecy marginalize it
saying that it is
cultish
saying that it is cultish they are on a
very slippery slope they might be
scholars
they might even have studied at the
great universities of the world
but they are not cleverer than
the thus says the lord so martin
how do we appropriate the righteousness
of christ and how do we know that we
have appropriated it
we appropriate it to the help of jesus
and the holy spirit
and we know
if we keep the commandments
all of it
so that which he has given to our trust
either in the word of god or in the
spirit of prophecy is the road map
and any deviation from that is not in
harmony with the spirit of god
may god give us wisdom
to remain faithful to his cause
which is
given to this church this is the apple
of his eye
but if everybody doesn't want to run
with it
that is to be god's problem yes and not
my don't or yours discouraged if you
have see this correct let's pray
heavenly father
we are living in such serious times
and we're getting such discordant
information
for and against issues
it is only by the spirit of god
that we will be able to stand in the
last days
lord make us instruments
that will receive the latter rain and
bring the loud cry
because soon you will come with the
clouds of heaven
and then this issue will have been
forever determined
help us to this effect in jesus name
amen amen
[Music]
you